.
Freunde der Sonne,
ihr habt viele Fragen,
aber diese ist besonders häufig.
Es geht um Handys, WLAN, und darum,
dass wir ständig bestrahlt werden.
Ist das jetzt gefährlicher Elektro-
smog oder unnötige Panikmache?
Um das zu klären,
habe ich mich heute mit...
"kurzgesagt" zusammengeschlossen.
Yes, das ist die Colabo, auf
die wir alle schon gewartet haben.
Und wenn ihr bei diesem Thema
wirklich durch steigen möchtet,
solltet ihr euch auch beide Videos
anschauen,die Reihenfolge ist egal.
Hauptsache,
ihr bekommt die ganze Story,
weil sie
gerade von "kurzgesagt" kommt.
Und natürlich auch Hi von mir.
Was auch immer ihr schon zu
diesem Thema wisst, eins fällt auf:
Es scheint echt wenige Studien
mit Menschen zu geben.
Bei diesen wenigen Studien
ist anscheinend keine dabei,
bei der sich jemand hinstellt
und sagt: So, hiermit ist bewiesen,
dass Handystrahlung
für Menschen ungefährlich ist.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Wir leben in einer Zeit
des technischen Fortschritts,
wo Menschen auf
den Mond fliegen können.
Warum ist es nicht möglich,
diese Frage
wissenschaftlich zu beantworten?
Oder wird uns da etwas verheimlicht?
Freunde der Sonne, holt euch
einen Tee, macht es euch gemütlich,
wir gehen der Sache auf den Grund.
* Titelmusik *
Erst mal eine ganz kurze Einleitung:
Kurzgesagt, quasi.
Handy- und WLAN-Strahlung
ist die Mikrowellenstrahlung.
Wie ihr vom Mikrowellenherd wisst,
kann die Strahlung Gewebe erwärmen.
Je intensiver die Strahlung,
desto stärker die Erwärmung.
Auch ohne,
dass wir gleich gebraten werden,
kann Erwärmung
gesundheitsschädlich sein.
Dafür gibt es für Handys, WLAN usw.
Grenzwerte, die verhindern,
dass der Kopf beim Telefonieren
nicht schädlich erwärmt wird.
Für Kopferhitzung gibt es natürlich
noch andere Gefahrenquellen...
Was? Ich soll die ein Shampoo
ohne Chemie mitbringen?
Die Frage ist jetzt, trotz
der Einhaltung der Grenzwerte,
kann Handy- oder WLAN-Strahlung
doch gesundheitsschädlich sein?
Und zwar aufgrund von irgendwelchen
biologischen Prozessen,
die über diese Erwärmung
hinausgehen?
Also sogenannte:
hier gibt es einige
Sorgen und Befürchtungen.
Von leichten Beschwerden wie
Kopfschmerzen oder Unwohlsein,
bis hin zu der Angst
vor schwerwiegenden Folgen,
wie Unfruchtbarkeit oder Krebs.
Ist da was dran?
Nehmen wir mal die Sorge Krebs
als konkretes Beispiel.
Stellt euch vor, ihr wärt Forscher,
ihr müsstet die Frage beantworten:
Ich meine es wirklich ernst,
stellt es euch wirklich vor.
Wir machen jetzt
eine Art Gedankenexperiment,
denn es gibt zu diesem Thema
tatsächlich gar nicht so wenige
wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse,
aber nur, wenn ihr lernt,
wie eine Forscherin zu denken,
dann könnt ihr diese Ergebnisse
auch sinnvoll einordnen
und interpretieren.
Und diese allgemeine Denke
könnt ihr in Zukunft auch
auf alle anderen
wissenschaftlichen Themen anwenden.
Bei Forschung geht es nicht
nur um die Forschungsfrage,
in diesem Fall: "Kann
Handystrahlung Krebs verursachen?",
sondern immer auch um die Methoden.
D.h., was wir denn genau anstellen,
um diese Frage zu beantworten.
Also, was stellen wir an?
Bei solchen medizinischen Fragen
fängt man meist beim Labor an.
Das bedeutet verschiedene
Experimente mit Zellen,
"in vitro" sagt man auch dazu, und,
Versuche an lebenden Organismen,
spricht Tierversuche,
auch "in vivo" genannt.
Konkret heißt das, ihr würdet
Zellen und Tiere bestrahlen,
und schauen, ob etwas passiert,dabei
könnt ihr systematisch vorgehen.
Ihr könnt Labortiere z.B. gut ver-
gleichen, sie sind so gezüchtet,
dass sie genetisch gleich
oder sehr ähnlich sind.
Da könnte sicherstellen,
dass Unterschiede eben nicht
auf genetische Unterschiede
zurückzuführen sind.
Und ihr könnt auch die Dauer
und die Intensität der Strahlung
sehr genau einstellen.
So stellt ihr vielleicht fest, dass
ab einer gewissen Strahlendosis
eine bestimmte Krebsart häufiger
auftritt. Wenn das passiert,
ist das ein ernstzunehmender Hin-
weis,den ihr weiter verfolgen müsst.
Und übrigens, je nachdem,
wie eindeutig die Ergebnisse
und wie stark der Effekt ist,
kann es bereits ausreichen,
um die Grenzwerte zu senken, denn
hier gilt das Vorsorgeprinzip.
Wir müssen nicht und
wollen nicht darauf warten,
dass die Schädlichkeit
an Menschen eindeutig belegt ist.
Es reicht, wenn eine Gefahr
realistischerweise anzunehmen ist.
Doch die Zell- und Tierversuche
reichen nicht aus,
um die Schädlichkeit an Menschen
zu bestimmen, dafür müsst ihr,
ausgehend von euren Laborversuchen,
Studien an Menschen durchführen.
Nur, wie geht ihr da am besten vor?
Last mal rein systematisch denken
und noch nicht menschlich,
ist ja nur ein Gedankenexperiment,
dann wäre ein gutes Studiendesign
eine "randomisierte
kontrollierte Studie".
Kontrolliert bedeutet,
ihr habt neben einer Testgruppe
auch eine Kontrollgruppe.
Die Testgruppe wird mit
Handystrahlung bestrahlt,
die Kontrollgruppe nicht.
Und ihr schaut, ob es Unterschiede
gibt. Randomisiert heißt,
die Einteilung in Test- und
Kontrollgruppe übernehmt nicht ihr,
sondern ein
Computer-Zufallsprogramm.
So habt ihr keine Chance,
durch die Einteilung in die Gruppen
das Ergebnis zu verfälschen.
Ihr seht ja selbst, was
jetzt die Herausforderung ist.
Im Gegensatz zu Labormäusen,
die ihr super vergleichen konntet,
habt ihr jetzt viele,
verschiedene individuelle Menschen,
die sich stark unterscheiden.
Nicht nur genetisch,
sondern auch im Lebensstil,
also wie die sich ernähren,
ob die Sport machen, aber auch
in deren Umwelt, wo die leben,
ob die viele Abgase einatmen.
Und es ist schon schwer
genug Handystrahlung alleine
von diesen
anderen Faktoren zu trennen.
Da ist es wichtig, dass ihr
zumindest die Versuchsteilnehmer
möglichst zufällig in Test- und
Kontrollgruppe aufteilt,
damit diese beiden Gruppen
am Ende im Schnitt ähnlich sind,
und damit gut vergleichbar.
Außerdem ist so eine
Studie am besten doppelblind.
Das bedeutet, die Teilnehmer wissen
nicht, in welcher Gruppe sie sind.
Ob sie gerade bestrahlt werden,
oder nicht, und zweitens ihr,
die Forscher, wisst es auch nicht,
ihr kriegt anonyme Daten,
wertet sie aus, und erst
wenn die Auswertung fertig ist,
darf die Verblindung
gelüftet werden,
damit ihr nicht mit
eurem persönlichen Erwartungen
das Ergebnis
beeinflusst oder verfälscht.
Sei es bewusst oder unbewusst.
Ihr merkt schon, für Wissenschaftler
gilt: traue niemandem!
Und v.a. nicht dir selbst.
Das Studiendesign "randomisierte,
kontrollierte Studie"
gilt als der Goldstandard
in der evidenzbasierten Medizin.
D.h., randomisierte kontrollierte
Studien sind sehr aussagekräftig.
Doch für unsere konkrete Frage,
nämlich, "kann Handystrahlung
beim Menschen Krebs verursachen?",
kommt dieses Studiendesign leider
nicht infrage aus mehreren Gründen,
darunter 1.:
Zum Testen neuer Medikamente,
sind randomisierte
kontrollierte Studien vertretbar,
denn das Medikament hat sich
in vorangegangenen Laborversuchen
als potentielle Heilung erwiesen.
Bei Handystrahlung
ist es andersrum, hier hat sich
eine intensive Bestrahlung im Labor
als potenziell gefährlich erwiesen.
Und auch, wenn nur Verdacht
auf eine Gefährdung besteht,
darf ich Studienteilnehmern
aus ethischen Gründen
nicht systematisch
Schaden hinzufügen.
Klarer wird es, wenn wir
ein krasseres Beispiel nehmen,
z.B., jemand raucht
eine Schachtel Zigaretten pro Tag.
Dann kann ich diese Person
wissenschaftlich beobachten,
aber ich darf diese Person
nicht dazu auffordern,
eine Schachtel Zigaretten pro Tag
zu rauchen für eine Studie.
Das ist ethisch nicht vertretbar.
Doch selbst abgesehen davon:
Ihr müsst es euch einfach nur
vorstellen, eure Kontrollgruppe
darf keiner Strahlung ausgesetzt
sein, keine Handystrahlung,
keiner WLAN-Strahlung, d.h.
ihr müsstet die Kontrollgruppe
irgendwie in einen Wald setzen,
wo kein Empfang ist,
und selbst,
wenn ihr das hinbekommen würdet,
dann wäre das ganze
erstens nicht verblindet,
und zweitens bekommt ihr
noch ein anderes Problem:
Nämlich, die Leute sind dann völlig
von der Außenwelt abgeschlossen.
Und damit wäre eure Kontrollgruppe
wirklich nicht mehr vergleichbar
mit der Testgruppe.
Sagen wir, ihr stellt fest,
dass die Waldgruppe gesünder lebt,
dann kann das an der
fehlenden Handystrahlung liegen,
es kann aber auch an
allem Möglichem anderen liegen.
Daran, dass die Leute sich mehr
bewegen, mehr frische Luft haben,
vielleicht mehr schlafen usw.
Oder, man müsste beide Gruppen
in den Wald bringen,
und nur eine davon bestrahlen,
aber dann wären wir
wieder beim ethischen Problem.
Also, ihr seht selbst,
es geht nicht. Also anders.
Wenn wir die Frage nicht
experimentell beantworten können,
müssen wir beobachten.
Beobachtende Studien
sind ein wichtiger Teil
evidenzbasierter Medizin. Ein
Beispiel ist die "Kohortenstudie".
Eine Kohorte ist eine Gruppe
von Studienteilnehmern,
die ich über einen langen Zeitraum,
Jahre/Jahrzehnte hinweg, beobachte.
Für unsere Frage brauchen
wir eine Gruppe von Menschen,
die zu Studienbeginn
alle gesund sind,
die nächsten Jahre
checken wir sie regelmäßig durch,
wir schauen, wie
viel sie ihr Handy benutzen,
und, wie es mit ihrer Gesundheit
steht und nach Jahren beobachten wir
wie viele der Teilnehmer
Krebs bekommen haben,
und ob die Betroffenen sehr häufig
ihr Handy benutzt haben,
oder eben auch nicht, klingt erst
mal nach einem guten Studiendesign.
Ist es prinzipiell auch.
Zum Thema Handystrahlung läuft im
Moment eine große Kohortenstudie.
Die Cosmos-Studie, die untersucht,
ob Handystrahlung
der Gesundheit schaden kann.
Die Studie hat ein Auge auf Hirn-
tumore und andere evtl. Krankheiten
und besteht aus sechs großen
Kohorten, aus sechs EU-Ländern.
Die erste Kohorte startete 2007
und die Studienteilnehmer
sollen insgesamt 20-30 Jahre
beobachtet werden.
Während eine Kohortenstudie
nicht so systematisch ist
wie eine experimentelle Studie,
liegt genau da auch ein Vorteil.
Denn, während Laborsettings
oft nicht alltagsrelevant sind,
beobachten wir hier die Menschen
in ihrem echten, alltäglichen Leben.
Und die echten,
realen Auswirkungen.
Jetzt gibt es aber bei Kohorten-
studien einen wesentlichen Nachteil:
Sie eignen sich nicht
für seltene Krankheitsfälle.
Sagen wir, Handystrahlung löst
in einem von 1000 Fällen Krebs aus,
nur so als Beispiel, und wir
beobachten jetzt 10.000 Menschen,
und zehn Menschen kriegen
durch Handystrahlung Krebs,
dann werden wir
diesen Effekt nicht bemerken.
Das könnt ihr euch schon
selbst denken, seltene Gefahren
sind nur mit riesigen
Kohortenstudien zu beobachten.
Das ist schwierig.
Und, wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt,
auch ziemlich teuer.
Was könnte man denn noch machen?
Wir können statt einer "prospektiven
Studie", also vorausschauend,
eine respektive Studie machen,
also zurückschauend. Was heißt das?
Schauen wir uns ein konkretes
Beispiel an: die Case Control Studie
Wir suchen uns zwei Gruppen
von Studienteilnehmern.
Eine mit Krebs,
das ist die Case-Gruppe.
Und eine gesunde Gruppe,
die Control-Gruppe.
Case Control-Studien eignen
sich für seltene Krankheitsfälle,
denn ich suche mir hier bewusst
Leute mit Case aus.
Aber jetzt kommt das schwierige: Im
Gegensatz zu einer Kohortenstudie,
wo ich die Menschen jahrelang
begleitete,muss ich jetzt versuchen,
rückblickend herauszufinden,
wie viel Strahlung
diese Menschen ausgesetzt waren.
In den letzten Jahren
oder Jahrzehnten.
Und, ob es einen Unterschied gab
zwischen Case- und der Controlgruppe
- das meiste bekommt man
nur durch Befragung heraus.
Oder durch andere,
ungenaue Methoden.
Z.B. schaut man sich
Handyverträge an, und versucht,
daraus zurückzuschließen,
wie viel die Menschen
ihr Handy genutzt haben.
Aber akkurat gibt dass die Strahlen-
belastung natürlich nicht wieder.
Außerdem unterliegen Case Control
Studien einem "Recall Bias".
Sagen wir, ich habe Krebs, werde im
Rahmen einer solchen Studie befragt,
wie oft ich mein Handy benutzt
habe in den letzten Jahren,
jetzt habe ich vielleicht
schon mal gehört, das Handystrahlung
und Krebs irgendwie
zusammenhängt und das führt dazu,
dass ich mich viel stärker daran
erinnere, wie oft ich mein Handy
benutzt habe, als jemand
aus der Kontroll-Gruppe.
Dieser Erinnerungsbias verzerrt
also die Ergebnisse der Befragung.
Jetzt leuchtet euch wahrscheinlich
ein, warum es auf die Frage:
"Kann Handy Strahlung Krebs
verursachen?", bisher noch
keine eindeutigen Antworten
aus Studien mit Menschen gibt.
D.h. jetzt aber auch nicht,
dass wir wild behaupten können,
das Handystrahlung gefährlich sei,
oder dass sie Insekten tötet,
oder was auch immer man dazu hört.
Das beruht auf keinen
wissenschaftlichen Daten.
D.h. aber auch nicht,
dass wir völlig hilflos sind und für
immer unwissend bleiben werden.
Wie gesagt, große Kohorten-Studien
laufen derzeit noch.
Außerdem habt
ihr ja selbst gesehen,
dass verschiedene Methoden ver-
schiedene Vor- und Nachteile haben.
Und gute Forschung zieht viele
verschiedene Methoden hinzu.
Und setzt sie zusammen,
wie eine Art Puzzle,
z.B. brauchen wir neben den
recht anwendungsbezogenen Studien
mit Menschen auch ein grundlegendes
biochemisches Verständnis
für den Mechanismen,
die z.B. hinter Handystrahlung
und Krebs stecken könnten.
Und das ist sehr wichtig,
es gibt bisher noch
keine schlüssige Hypothese.
Noch keine Vorstellung davon,
wie Handystrahlung Krebs überhaupt
theoretisch auslösen könnte.
Es gibt keinen plausiblen
biologischen Mechanismus dafür.
D.h. nicht, dass man
es nicht erforschen sollte,
aber ist ein gutes Zeichen dafür,
dass man nicht in
Panik verfallen sollte.
Ich würde jetzt an dieser Stelle
zur Visualisierung Tee trinken,
aber es ist heute einfach
zu heiß in meinem Studio.
Wenn ihr jetzt genau wissen wollt
welche Puzzleteile die Forschung
bisher gesammelt hat, was
man mit Gewissheit sagen kann,
und was Elektrosmog
eigentlich bisher ist,
findet ihr diese
Antworten bei "kurzgesagt".
Und wenn ihr schon mal da seid,
hinterlasst dem "kurzgesagt"-Team
doch ein paar Keks-Emojis.
Vorher könnte mir aber gerne
in den Kommentaren verraten,
ie ihr mit diesem Thema im Alltag
umgeht, macht die euch Sorgen,
unternehmt er irgendwas, legt ihr
euer Handy möglichst weit weg?
Beim Schlafen z.B.? Oder seid ihr
da ganz entspannt und optimistisch?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare,
wir sehen uns nächste Woche,
bis dahin bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2019)